>>> WEEK 17 FELLOWS, NFL BETS
WE LOVE.
GETS THE THURSDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL EDITION. HOPEFULLY YOU
ARE READY.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP AND ON
TWITTER FOR YOUR LOCKS TONIGHT.
RYAN, LET'S PULL UP TWITTER.
LET'S PULL UP TWITTER AND SEE
WHAT THE PEOPLE HAD TO SAY.
>> I HAVE SOMETHING ELSE PULLED
UP ON TWITTER BEFORE WE GET TO
THAT.
IF WE JUST WANT TO ROLL THE
CLIP FROM LAST WEEK.
I THINK WE WERE TRYING TO
DECIDE ON AND ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORE LAST WEEK, AND
I HAD IT TOSSED TO ME THAT I
GAVE OUT A PICK.
I COULDN'T REMEMBER WHO.
LET'S JUST SEE.
>> SHOULD WE PUT OUR FOOT DOWN?
>> TREVOR LAWRENCE HAD YOU TYPE
THAT?
>> NO.
SHOULD WE PUT OUR FOOT DOWN
SAM?
>> THIS IS IT.
>> IT'S 400.
>> NOT THOUGHT OF IN?
>> I'M CUT OFF BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T SCORE A TOUCHDOWN, BUT I
THINK I BROUGHT UP TREVOR
LAWRENCE, AND I THINK TREVOR
LAWRENCE WAS THE ONLY PERSON
WHO SCORED A TOUCHDOWN.
NO COMMENT?
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> YOU KNOW WHEN THEY STARTED
THE SHORE THIS SHOW, THERE WAS
A GRAPHIC BELOW THAT THAT IT
WAS WEEK 17, AND YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT WEEK 16.
>> I JUST WANT TO SET THE
PRECEDENT FOR WHEN I BRING UP
SOMEBODY WHO'S TOUCHDOWN ALTAR
MAYBE +300 TONIGHT AND HE
LAUGHED ME OFF THE STAGE, THAT
A +600 PLATE WOULD'VE HIT LAST
WEEK. SAM IS MORE INTERESTED AT
-250.
TELL ME WHAT DO I DO.
>> WE DO THIS PARLAY SEGMENT
FOR 20 MINUTES, AND A TON OF
NAMES AND DEBTS ARE THROWN OUT
THERE, AND IF THE PARLAY ENDS
UP LOSING, YOU WILL GO BACK AND
FIND ONE BET THAT YOU DISCUSSED
WHEN THERE ARE 15 OTHERS THAT
WE DISCUSSED THAT DIDN'T HIT
AND ONLY BRING UP THAT ONE.
YOU KNOW WHO SHOULD BE TALKING
CRAP RIGHT NOW?
IT SHOULD BE GREG.
GREG HAD THE JAGUARS LAST WEEK
AND TALKED ABOUT HOW BAD ZACH
WILSON WAS, AND YOU AND I WERE
IDIOTS AND WE TRUSTED ZACH
WILSON AND WE LOST.
KUDOS TO GREG.
>> I TOLD YOU GUYS.
I TOLD YOU GUYS, ZACH WILSON,
DO NOT BELIEVE IN HIM AT ALL.
YOU KNOW HOW THAT GOES.
RYAN, YOU DIDN'T, YOU DID CALL
THE TREVOR LAWRENCE.
YOU DID CALL THE TRAVEL
LAWRENCE, BLAKE SAM SAID, WE
DISCUSS SO MANY PLAYS LAST
WEEK.
>> I HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME
EDITING TOOLS THAT YOU DO, SAM.
YOUR UNWILLINGNESS TO CLIP ME
IS YOUR DOWNFALL.
THAT'S IT.
>> I THINK THE COWBOYS ARE THE
BETTER TEAM. TONIGHT.
DEFINITELY TONIGHT'S GAME.
>> RYAN WANTS TO START A CLIP
OR SO I GUESS THAT IS WHAT THIS
SHOW IS GOING TO TURN INTO.
WE WILL BRING IN A BUNCH OF
CLIPS FROM THE PREVIOUS OT YOU
GUYS IN THE CURRENT SHOW AND
JUST TALK ABOUT US BEING WRONG
AND RIGHT.
I GUESS THAT IS WHAT THE SHOW
IS GOING TO BECOME.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW EVERYBODY.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY.
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN, THE
MYTH, THE LEGEND I CALL HIM SAM
THE SHARP RICH, BUT YOU MIGHT
CALL HIM SAM RICHMOND.
NEXT TO HIM IS THE GUY THAT
CONNECTS THE CHAT TO US.
WE LIKE TO CALL HIM PRODUCER
RYAN.
HE LIKES TO CALL HIMSELF THE
MAN OF THE PEOPLE, BUT, HE IS A
MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS DROP YOUR
LOCKS IN THE CHAT.
WE WILL BE GRADING YOUR PICKS
AT THE END OF THE SHOW.
RIGHT NOW WE NEED YOUR HELP
BUILDING A SAME GAME PARLAY FOR
THURSDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL.
RYAN, TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE
NEED.
>> WE NEED MANY LEGS, FIVE.
WE NEED FIVE LEGS FROM YOU
GUYS.
I HAVE THE TWEET PULLED UP FROM
EARLIER.
ASKED ON TWITTER FOR A LEG IN
THIS SAME GAME PARLAY, JUMP IN
THE CHAT AND LET US KNOW WHAT
YOU LIKE TONIGHT AND WE WILL
DISCUSS IT, BUT LET US PIN A
TWITTER REPLY AGAINST A CHAT
COMMENT RIGHT NOW. LET'S SEE.
LET'S SEE.
DAK PRESCOTT OVER 19.5
COMPLETIONS.
HE MIGHT NOT EVEN HAVE TO THROW
19 PASSES TONIGHT.
HE MAY NOT HAVE TO DO IT.
>> I LIKE TONY POLLARD 2+ TDs.
THAT'S A GOOD BET.
I LIKE THAT ONE.
>> I ALSO LIKE THAT THIS PERSON
JUMPED IN HERE AND SAID NO LUCK
BUT LAMB ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN,
JUST OWNING THE FACT THAT YOU
DON'T THINK IT'S A LOCK.
>> DON'T GET IT.
>> ZEKE ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN.
ZEKE TO TD.
MALIK DAVIS, THIS IS ALSO A
POPULAR ONE.
THOMPSON, 3+ SACKS FOR DALLAS
IN THE CHAT.
HOW DO WE WANT TO GO ABOUT THIS,
GENTLEMEN?
WHO WANTS TO DRAW FIRST BLOOD?
>> I THINK WE SHOULD START THEM
UP WE DON'T WANT TO TOUCH ANY
SPREAD IN THIS PARLAY.
TO ME I FEEL LIKE, ALL RIGHT, I
MEAN, THIS IS MY PERSPECTIVE.
THE SPREAD FEELS COMPLETELY
UNBEARABLE IN MY OPINION.
I WILL THROW THAT OUT THERE.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO
BET THIS GAME IN TERMS OF IF
YOU THINK THE COWBOYS ARE GOING
TO BEAT UP ON THE TITANS.
ALSO BEFORE WE MOVE OVER TO
DRAFTKINGS HERE,  DALTON
SCHULTZ ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN.
>> I WAS GOING TO TOUCH ON THE
ANYTIME TD FACTOR BECAUSE LAST
WEEK'S PARLAY MOBLEY WANTED TO
THROW IN AN ANYTIME TD TO SORT
OF JUICE UP THE ODDS, AND IT
WAS THE ONLY LEG THAT THEY HIT,
AND NO ONE HAD ANY SUGGESTIONS
OF WHAT THE WINNING ANYTIME TD
THAT WOULD BE WHICH ENDED UP
BEING TREVOR LAWRENCE.
MY GUT, WE STAY AWAY FROM
ANYTIME TD.
THE ONLY EXCEPTION, AND THIS
AGAIN IS MY TAKES.
THE ONLY EXCEPTION WOULD BE
ZEKE, BECAUSE HE SHOULD BE A
LOCK.
ANYONE ELSE, I DON'T WANT TO DO
CD OR GALA FOR HASKINS.
I DON'T WANT TO MESS WITH ANY
OF THOSE TO JUICE UP THE
PARLAY.
I WANT TO DO THE PLAYER PROPS
WHICH WE PROVED LAST WEEK THAT
WE ARE GURUS AT.
>> I AGREE.
LET'S LOCK IN ZEKE.
I MEAN, EVERYONE IN THE
COMMENTS WANTS ZEKE.
A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT YOU
JUST READ IN THAT TWITTER
RESPONSE WANTED ZEKE.
>> BETSY ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN YOU
WANT TO GO FOR?
THE COWBOYS ARE GOING TO SCORE
A GAZILLION POINTS TONIGHT AND
YOU DON'T THINK --
>> THEY ARE NOT.
THE TOTAL IS 40.
>> WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH ANYTHING?
TOTAL IS 40 BECAUSE DOBBS IS
THE QUARTERBACK.
>> IT MEANS THE COWBOYS ARE
GOING TO GET A BIG AND PROBABLY
NOT, ONCE I GET UP 14, 17
POINTS --
>> THE COWBOYS ARE GOING TO GET
UP BIG.
HOW DO YOU GET UP BIG?
>> BY HANDING THE BALL TO ZEKE.
>> BY SCORING TOUCHDOWNS.
>> ANTHONY JUMPED IN AND SAID
HE LIKES COWBOYS OVER 2.5
TOUCHDOWNS.
I THINK IF WE WANT TO DO A
LOCK, LET'S ADD THAT IN THERE.
>> LET ME, YOU KNOW, SHOW ME
THE NUMBERS.
I AM AN ODD GUY.
>> REMEMBER, ZEKE WAS -195.
>> THAT SHOULD BE IN THE
PARLAY.
>> I'M NOT PUTTING IN ZEKE IS A
JUICY COOL PLAY.
AND PUTTING IT IN LIKE EVAN
INGRAM OVER 2.5 RECEPTIONS AT
-5000 LAST WEEK.
>> AND YOU ARE USING THAT AS AN
ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN?
WHY.
>> THAT'S THE ONLY ONE I'M
WILLING TO CONSIDER.
AFTER THAT I DON'T WANT TO DO
ANY TIME TDs.
>> RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS A SCHOOL OF THOUGHT
THING THAT WE ARE FIGHTING ON
RIGHT HERE.
I REALLY THINK, WE HAVE --
>> WHY ARE WE GOING TO RISK
WHAT IS GOING TO END UP BEING A
LOCKED PARLAY ON MICHAEL GALLO
+225 SCORE TOUCHDOWN?
>> I AGREE WITH SAM.
>> LET'S SAVE ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN FOR LAST.
WE WILL CIRCLE BAST WE WILL
CIRCLE BACK POINT
>> JUST START OFF THE LEG.
THERE IS NO SCENARIO WHERE THAT
DOES NOT HIT.
>> THERE IS NO SCENARIO FOR
THIS ONE DOESN'T HIT, OVER 2.5.
>> BRIAN.
BRIAN.
>> IT'S -800, GREG.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> WE KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO
SCORE 2.
>> THE DEFENSE IS PROBABLY
GOING TO SCORE TONIGHT THAT IS
HOW MANY TOUCHDOWNS ARE GOING
TO BE SCORED.
>> ASK THE AUDIENCE.
>> JORDAN GRIMM SAID ZEKE IS
TOO EASY.
I AGREE.
>> THIS IS THE SAME JUICE.
GIVE ZEKE IS EASY, YOU MIGHT AS
WELL TAKE ZEKE --
>> BAGEL AND LOCKS OVER 2.5
PLEASE WITH 4Z.
BRIAN, IT DO YOUR COWBOYS OVER
26.5 POINT AGAIN, STAY TUNED.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD ASK THE
CHAT, DO YOU WANT THIS PARLAY
TO HIT, OR DO YOU WANT AN 8-1
OR 10-1 PARLAY.
IF WE WANT TO GO 10-1 PARLAY,
AND GO FOR IT, I'M FINE WITH
THAT, BUT IF THE CHAT WANTS US
TO WIN, THEN I THINK WE KNOW
NEED TO START LOOKING AT OVER
1.5 TOUCHDOWNS.
>> I LOVE THAT REASONING.
WE ARE TRYING TO WIN.
I MEAN, AS PRETTY AS THESE
PARLAY TICKETS THAT ARE LIKE 12-
1, 14-1 --
>> DEVELOPER LAST WEEK AT THE
END OF THE SHOW WHEN GREG WAS
GOING THROUGH THE PARLAY, AND
HE WAS LISTING OFF THE LEGS AND
I SAID LOCK OVER EVERYTHING AND
WE GOT TO ETIENNE TOUCHDOWN AND
I SAID IT MIGHT NOT HIT, I WENT
EVERY ONE OF THESE LEGS  FOR ME
TO BE ABLE TO SAY LOCK.
>> I AGREE .1 .5 TOUCHDOWN --
>> 15 YEARS OF MY LIFE --
>> 1.5 TOUCHDOWNS?
>> IT'S SO JUICY.
>> DANTE ROTELLA SAYS OVER TO
.5 TOUCHDOWNS SEEMS TOO EASY.
LET'S REMEMBER IT'S THE
COWBOYS.
>> WAS JUST SLOT IN ONE .5, AND
WE ARE ONLY ONE LEG IN.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> LITERALLY LAST WEEK -- I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU THINK
BECAUSE IT'S +200 MEANS, LIKE,
IT'S MORE LIKELY TO HIT IN
TERMS OF THE ODDS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S GOING TO
HIT.
WE MIGHT AS WELL TRY TO MAKE
LEGITIMATE CASH OFF OF THIS
RATHER THAN BUILD A FIFE LAKE
PARLAY THAT'S -185.
>> YOU ARE THROWING A BUNCH OF
BIG WORDS AT ME.
>> YOUR STRATEGY HAS NOT LED US
TO THE PROMISED LAND IN THE
LAST 3 TO 4 WEEKS.
>> WE WANT TO WIN.
WE WILL WANT THE MONEY.
WIN.
>> WE WANT TO WIN.
>> WHATEVER.
>> RYAN, I LOVE YOU, AND I KNOW
YOUR RECORD ON THE SHOW IS
REALLY GOOD.
>> PRISTINE.
>> ACCORDING TO YOU.
BUT BROTHER, WE ARE TRYING TO
WIN.
WE ARE TRYING TO WIN HERE, AND
YOUR STRATEGY OF GETTING RICH,
I MEAN, IT JUST HASN'T LED US
TO PAYDIRT.
>> WE HAVE LOCKED THAT IN
TEMPORARILY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE THROWING
OUT SIX IN THE COMMENTS.
>> THOMPSON HAS THREE SACKS .
>> WHERE ARE THE TEAM SACKS.
>> TEAM SACKS IS INTERESTING,
BUT SO IS --
>> WHAT ARE THE TEAM SACKS?
>> I LIKE THAT MICHAEL PARSONS
ONE SACK.
HE'S BEEN SLUMPING.
>> I LIKE IT AS WELL.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
>> TO.
WHY NOT.
WE SHOULD ASK THE AUDIENCE.
>> THIS IS JUICY.
-160.
TALK DIRTY TO ME.
>> YEAH.
>> WE HAVE TO GO TO ANOTHER
SECTION FOR TEAM SACKS.
>> I WILL KEEP MOVING.
BUT, LET'S SEE.
I AM CURIOUS THE CHATS TAKE ON
MICHAEL PARSONS SACKS.
>> GIVE US A THUMBS-UP OR
THUMBS DOWN ON MICHAEL PARSONS
TO GET ONE SACK TONIGHT.
I THINK HE IS DO.
HE WAS THE DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF
THE YEAR.
HE HAD IT BOOKED.
BUT THEN THAT BOY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO, YOU KNOW -- HE JUST
TOOK OVER.
HE JUST TOOK OVER.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
CASE HERE, SAM.
>> I THINK BAGEL AND LOCKS LIED
TO US.
IT'S USUALLY IN THAT SECTION.
OKAY.
LET'S SEE WHAT ELSE THE CHAT
HAS.
SOMEONE THROUGHOUT TITANS TO
LOSE A FUMBLE.
>> COWBOYS FAN PICKING A
COWBOYS OVER, SHOCKER.
IT IS THE PRACTICE SQUAD
TITANS.
>> A LOT OF CD LOVE.
I DON'T WANT TO TOUCH
TOUCHDOWNS, BUT I'M WILLING TO
ENTERTAIN MORE ATTAINABLE CD
PROPS.
>> I AM SEEING LAMB OVER 54.5
YARDS.
IT SEEMS LIKE --
>> YOU MIGHT LOCK THIS ONE.
YOU MIGHT LIKE THIS ONE.
DALTON SCHULTZ OVER 39.5.
>> I'M NOT BIG ON THE YARDS.
IF SOMEBODY WERE IN A
HYPOTHETICAL SENT TO JUMP IN
HERE AND SAY ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN, I WOULD ENTERTAIN IT.
SAM WOULDN'T ENTERTAIN IT, NOT
FOR ONE SECOND.
>> LAMB OVER 54.5 RECEIVING
YARDS.
>> AND ALL ODD AND SEE, LIKE,
SHOULD WE --
>> DID YOU SEE WHAT I JUST SAW?
GREG ARIAN?
>> YES.
>> I LOVE THAT.
THAT IS A GOOD ONE.
OUR MINDS BOTH WENT TO THE SAME
PLACE.
LET'S GO.
>> FOR THOSE WHO DIDN'T SEE IT,
DERION 85 SAID TITANS UNDER
17.5 TOTAL POINTS.
I LOVE THIS.
THAT IS SO GOOD THAT IS SO GOOD.
HERE WE GO.
ONLY -340?
>> THAT'S REALLY GOOD.
>> PLUS SIGN?
>> I LIKE THIS.
>> ADD ZEKE TO SCORE.
>> RITTER JUMPED IN AND SAID I
FEEL LIKE YARDS IS SAFER THAN
RECEPTIONS FOR CEEDEE.
I FEEL LIKE YEAH , THAT'S TRUE.
>> I'M KIND OF SCARED OF A
MICHAEL PARSONS SACK.
CAN I JUST SAY THAT?
>> ARE YOU?
>> YEAH.
HE'S HAD ONE SACK IN HIS LAST
FOUR GAMES, AND WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE -235?
>> THAT IS WHY HE'S DUE.
>> THE ONLY THING I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT WITH IT IS THE TITANS
COULD VERY WELL JUST RUN THE
NAVY OFFENSE TONIGHT AND NOT
THROW IT ONCE.
YOU KNOW?
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> DOBBS SIGNED OFF --
>> CAN WE GO BACK TO CEEDEE?
THAT IS MY SUGGESTION.
THAT I WILL CLIP OUT LATER.
>> WE ARE BEING DARED TO TAKE
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD ASK THE
CHAT, THUMBS-UP OR THUMBS DOWN
IF WE SHOULD TAKE ZEKE ANYTIME
T.D.
>> DON'T PUT WORDS IN THE CHATS
MOUTH.
NOBODY SPECIFICALLY RIGHT NOW
IN THIS CURRENT STATE, OR THIS
CURRENT ITERATION OF THE CHAT,
IN THIS CURRENT ITERATION OF
THE CHAT IS SAYING ZEKE TO
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
>> ZEKE ANYTIME VERSUS COWBOYS,
IT'S LIKE THE FIFTH CHAT OR
COMMENT FROM THE TOP.
>> I'M NOT SEEING IT.
>> PEOPLE LIKE THE CEEDEE OVER.
>> CEEDEE OVER RECEIVING YARDS?
54.5 ? DO YOU GUYS LIKE THE
CEEDEE OVER?
WE NEED TO BE HONEST AS A
FAMILY . NO.
>> I GOT --
>> I HAVE FANTASY OBLIGATIONS
THIS WEEK.
>> I WAS JUST ABOUT TO ASK YOU.
>> GOING UP AGAINST CEEDEE AND
DAK.
I'M HONEST.
>> LAST TWO GAMES, 120 YARDS,
126 YARDS , TO ME THAT'S A HIT.
>> IT'S WORTH IT.
IT'S WORTH A SPRINKLE.
>> I MEAN, IT WAS THE SAME
ODYSSEY PARSONS SACK.
WE ARE BACK AT THE SAME SPOT WE
WERE.
>> I THINK HE HAS A BETTER
CHANCE OF HITTING.
PARSONS HAS A SACKED TWICE IN
HIS LAST FIVE GAMES.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE IS A GOOD
CHANCE OF HITTING?
ZEKE TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
HE SCORED IN HIS LAST EIGHT OR
SEVEN GAMES.
>> I THINK WE NEED TO ASK THE
CHAT JUST FOR THE THUMBS-UP OR
THUMBS DOWN ON ZEKE.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
WE SAID WE WOULD LEAVE THIS TO
LAST TO SEE WHERE WE ARE AT.
LATER JUMPS IN AND SAYS A
PARLAY IS -205 RIGHT NOW.
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING.
I'VE LOST CONTROL AND I'M THE
ONE WHO'S ON DRAFTKINGS.
>> BRIAN, ARE YOU AFRAID TO LET
THE CHAT PICK?
HAVE OF THIS IS LIKE YOUR
PROPAGANDA, A MAJORITY OF IT.
IT IS INFLUENCED BY YOUR
PROPAGANDA.
BUT WHEN WE WANT TO ASK THE
CHAT YOU ARE ANTI-CHAT WHEN THE
SHOW IS ABOUT THE CHAT.
>> I'M NOT ANTI-CHAT.
MOST OF THESE PLAYS, CURRENTLY
THE PLAYS THAT ARE IN HERE ARE
OVER 1.5 COWBOYS TOUCHDOWNS.
WITH THE CHAT WANTED WAS TO .5
TOUCHDOWNS.
MY ONLY BEEF RIGHT NOW IS THAT
YOU GUYS SEE A CHAT, AND YOU
TEASE IT DOWN.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT THE PARLAY
WILL CHANGE OUT IF WE CHANGE IT
TO 2.5.
>> LOOK AT ALL OF THE ZEKE.
BRIAN, WHY ARE YOU NOT
LISTENING TO US?
BE WARM SAYS BRIAN, WHY ARE YOU
NOT LISTENING TO US?
EVERYONE HERE IS ON ZEKE.
JUST DO IT.
>> THROW IN ZEKE.
GO THROUGH IN ZEKE.
WE ARE TRYING TO LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS.
>> THEY ARE CALLING YOU ANTI-
CHECK ANTI-CHAT.
>> I'M GOING TO LOSE MY TITLE.
>> AS BEING THE MAN OF THE
PEOPLE, IS NOT A GOOD LUCK, BUT
THEY ARE CALLING YOU ANTI---
>> THIS IS PRETTY GOOD.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
I LIKE IT.
WE NEED ONE MORE.
WE NEED ONE MORE LOCK.
>> WE NEED TO GET US INTO THE
400 RANGE.
>> I PERSONALLY I WOULD BE A
FAN  OF MICHAEL GALLUP.
>> NO.
NO.
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
LET'S GO GET A LOCK, LIKE DAK
TO THROW OVER 200 YARDS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> GREG, I LIKE HOW YOU ARE
THINKING.
IF WE CAN GET THIS PUPPY INTO
+400.
>> I WANTED TO GET AUDIO
PADDING SO WHEN I CLIP IT OUT
--
>> I KNEW EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
>> THAT'S HILARIOUS.
LET'S SEE WHAT DAK --
>> 194.5?
>> YOU GUYS GOT THIS PICK FROM
THE CHAT?
>> NO.
>> ALL THE CHAT IS DOING RIGHT
NOW IS COMMENTING ON HOW THEY
WANT ZEKE.
>> ZEKE IS IN IT.
>> I KNOW.
THEY ARE STILL, YOU KNOW.
>> 773-1985 GALLUP T.D., THANK
YOU.
>> IT ALSO SAYS THE DAC OVER
200 YARDS PASSING.
>> DAK OVER 19 COMPLETIONS.
WE WILL DO THE 200 YARDS
PASSING.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE
ALTERNATE.
195 WORKS.
WHEN 95.
>> SCROLL UP.
195 IS PLUS -250.
SCROLL.
DO THE 194.5.
YEAH.
I THOUGHT THE SAME EXACT THING.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF IT WOULD BE A
PUSH IN 195.
I WORKED IT OUT IN MY HEAD.
>> GOT YOU.
>> +370.
I WANT TO GET THE 400.
>> CRAZY.
SAM WANTS TO GET IN THE 400
RANGE.
I MEAN WE CAN GO UP TO 220.
>> JOSH DOBBS INTERCEPTIONS.
>> IS GOING TO THROW IT FOUR
TIMES.
>> WHEN YOU GUYS WALK IN HERE,
DO YOU PLAN ON BEING DIFFICULT,
OR IS THIS A SPUR OF THE MOMENT
DEAL FOR YOU?
>> JUST TRYING TO WIN.
THAT'S IT.
>> SO WAIT, HOLD ON.
CALLED ON.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A FIVE
LEGGED PARLAY AND WE ALREADY
HAVE FIVE LEGS AND LOOK AT
WHERE WE ARE AT.
WE NEED TO FIGURE IT OUT.
>> ASSAM GOES THROUGH IT AND
SAYS LOCK AND IT WINDS  MY
DOESN'T MATTER THAT IT'S 370?
>> HOW ABOUT WE ASK IS THE MAN
OF THE PEOPLE, I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE CHAT, ARE WE OKAY WITH
THIS PARLAY AS IT IS CURRENTLY,
FIVE LEG +370.
ARE WE OKAY WITH THIS?
>> THUMBS UP, THUMBS DOWN.
>> IF YOU HAVE A THUMBS DOWN,
ADD YOUR OWN COMMENTARY,
PLEASE.
>> 773-1985 SAYS I'M STILL
SHOCKED AT BRIAN  THINKING HE'S
A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> THAT'S A GOOD TAKE.
>> THAT'S A GREAT TAKE.
>> I JUST WANT THUMBS-UP IF YOU
LIKE THE PARLAY, AND THUMBS
DOWN IF YOU WANT US TO CHANGE
SOMETHING.
THAT'S IT.
WE ARE PUTTING IT IN THE
PEOPLE'S HANDS.
>> DERION 85 SAYS JOSH DOBBS.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE ASKING.
I'M WAITING FOR THOSE TO COME
IN, BUT HE SAYS JOSH DOBBS
UNDER PASSING YARDS.
>> BAGEL AND LOCKS, MICHAEL
GALLUP T.D.
HAS LONGER ODDS IN THIS PARLAY.
CB, NO LET'S GET RICH.
TRUST IN BRIAN.
I NEED --
>> THAT IS YOUR TWITTER FINGERS.
>> IT SEEMS PRETTY SPLIT.
50-50.
>> THAT'S YOUR BURNER, RYAN.
>> WE HAVE SOME THUMBS DOWN.
DANTE THUMBS DOWN.
BETTER FIVE THUMBS DOWN.
JORDAN GRIMM THUMBS DOWN.
BEEF AND FLIPPED US OFF FIVE
TIMES.
R SMITH THUMBS DOWN.
>> SOMEBODY SAYS DAK GOT AGO.
>> WHAT ABOUT ZEKE GOT TO GO?
WHAT ABOUT IF WE GOT TO GO ZEKE
AND WE HAD IN DALTON SCHULTZ --
>> YOU KNOW, JUST FOR THE
CONTENT, I'M WILLING TO LET YOU
TAKE OUT ZEKE AND PUT IN
SOMETHING . IF THE CHAT
AGREEMENTS WITH YOU.
I NEED GREG'S SIGN OFF.
>> AM I GETTING PERMISSION?
>> IF GREG IS WITH THIS IN THE
CHAT AGREES WITH YOU, YOU CAN
TAKE OUT ZEKE AND PUT IN AND
ANYTIME T.D.
PARLAY, AND WE WILL GO WITH
THAT, AND NOAH BROWN DROPS A
TOUCHDOWN IN THE END ZONE.
>> CLEAN. MY SACRAMENTO PEOPLE
ARE BACK IN HERE.
>> GO AHEAD, RYAN.
>> IT'S YOUR SHOW.
>> DON'T SAY THAT.
OKAY.
'S BE
>> C LOOK AT HIM.
NOW THAT HE HAS THE PRESSURE ON
HIM AND THE DECISION TO MAKE,
NOT SO CONFIDENT NOW.
>> NOT WHAT I SAID.
I JUST WANT TO SEE WHERE THIS
NETS US.
I'M DEBATING BETWEEN DALTON
SCHULTZ  AND MICHAEL GALLUP.
HOW ABOUT THIS.
I'M GOING TO ASK THE CHAT.
DALTON SCHULTZ OR MICHAEL
GALLUP IN THIS PARLAY, OR
NEITHER  AND WE WILL SACRIFICE
RYAN, THAT WAS A COMMENT
DROPPED IN.
>> YOU RIGHT DALTON SCHULTZ,
MICHAEL GALLUP, OR ZEKE.
>> A REMINDER IF WE ADD ZEKE IT
IS +370.
WE KNOW WHAT THOSE ODDS LOOK
LIKE.
NOT TO SWAY THE DECISION AT
ALL.
I WOULD NEVER DO THAT.
B THOMPSON, DAK AT  4+75,
RITTER, AUSTIN HUBER, ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN.
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN PUTTING A
TITAN ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN WE ALSO
HAVE 13 TOTAL UNDER.
>> THEY SAID CHANGE ZEKE ANY
TIME TOUCHDOWN TO FIRST HALF
T.D.
>> OKAY, WHAT IF WE DO THAT.
>> ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE,
FIRST HALF THERE IN THE MID-.
OH, BABY. +575.
>> THAT, SEE, LOOK POINT ALL
RIGHT ERIC
>> WE HAVE SOME TAKES IN HERE.
I DON'T KNOW IF I LIKE THIS.
>> I SEE GALLUP.
I SEE ZEKE, ZEKE, ZEKE, I SEE
ONE DALTON SCHULTZ, ANOTHER
DALTON SCHULTZ,  ANOTHER
MICHAEL GALLUP.
>> IF SOMEONE SAID COWBOYS -6.5
IS A LOCK, AND I DO THINK THAT
IS A LOCK.
>> YOU STARTED THE SHOW SAYING
NO SPREADS.
>> BUT NOT -14.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS, YEAH,
THAT WAS IMPLIED THAT WE WERE
GOING TO TAKE -14.
>> PEOPLE ARE LIKING THE PARLAY
NOW.
THERE IS A LOT OF, ALL RIGHT, I
FEEL LIKE THIS IS IT.
WE'VE NEVER GOTTEN THIS MUCH
LOVE.
>> NOT TRUE.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> THIS IS IT.
IT'S OVER.
>> THERE IT IS.
THERE IT IS.
THERE IT IS, RYAN.
LOCK IT IN.
>> TO BE A MAN OF THE PEOPLE
YOU NEED TO BE A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
>> IT'S NOT THAT . YOU GUYS
PUSH THE CHAT IN A DIRECTION
WHERE IT IS A YES OR NO KIND OF
DEAL, AND I NEED, I,  THERE
WERE DALTON SCHULTZ TAKES AND
MICHAEL GALLUP TAKES, AND WE
JUST COMPLETELY --
>> AND THEN WE PUT THE ZEKE ONE
IN AND EVERYONE SAID YES I LOVE
THIS.
IT'S ALSO +526 . 5:26 EASTERN
TIME.
>> IF WE LIKE THIS LET'S DO IT.
LET'S GO OVER THIS.
>> WE ARE LOCKING IT IN.
>> YEAH, WE ARE LOCKING IT IN.
OKAY.
>> BEFORE WE LOCK IT IN, LET'S
TOSS IN A LITTLE COWBOYS -6.5.
WE WILL SEE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
ON TOP OF THIS.
WE CAN MAYBE PUSH THIS IN THE
700 TO 800 RANGE WITH ANOTHER
LOCK . IT INTO ANYTHING. WE ARE
TAKING THAT OUT.
WE ARE TAKING THAT OUT.
>> NO.
NO.
OFF RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS IT?
WE ARE GOOD?
WE ARE GOOD.
UNDER 17.5 TEAM TOTAL POINTS
FOR THE TENNESSEE TITANS.
OVER 54.5 RECEIVING YARDS FOR
CEEDEE THEM , OVER 2.5 TOTAL
TOUCHDOWNS FOR THE COWBOYS,
195+ PASSING YARDS FOR DAK
PRESCOTT, AND THEN AN ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN FOR ZEKE IN THE FIRST
HALF. FIVE LEG FOR  +575.
>> LET'S GO.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> I LIKE IT, RYAN.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> WE ARE WRITING.
WE ARE WRITING.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS TELL US ON
DRAFTKINGS.
IT'S THURSDAY NIGHT, SO WE HAVE
TO ASK.
WILL THERE BE AN OFFENSIVE
SCORE ON THE FIRST DRIVE?
IT IN THE COMMENTS AND LET US
KNOW, THUMBS-UP IF THERE IS
GOING TO BE A SCORE.
THUMBS DOWN IF THERE IS NOT.
RYAN , SAM, I WILL START OFF
WITH YOU GUYS BEFORE WE HOP
INTO THE CHAT. DO YOU GUYS
THINK THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE
A SCORE ON THE FIRST DRIVE
TONIGHT?
>> THIS ONE IS TOUGH BECAUSE IT
REALLY DOES COME DOWN TO WHO
GETS THE BALL FIRST.
IF THE TITANS GOT THE BALL
FIRST, IT IS A GUARANTEED NO.
IF THE COWBOYS GET THE BALL
FIRST, IT IS A VERY LIKELY YES.
I WOULD STILL, I WOULD LEAN NO
BECAUSE THERE IS NO CHANCE THE
TITANS SCORE ON THEIR FIRST
DRIVE WITH JOSH DOBBS, BUT IT
FEELS, YOU KNOW, IT'S RISKY,
BECAUSE IF THE COWBOYS GET THE
BALL YOU MIGHT BE TOAST.
>> RYAN , BEFORE YOU GO TO THE
CHAT, WHAT IS YOUR VERDICT ON
THE NOSE SCORE FIRST DRIVE?
>> I'M TRYING TO LOOK AT THE
STATS FOR HOW MANY COIN TOSS IS
THE COWBOYS HAVE WON THIS YEAR.
THEY HAVE WON 11.
11.
>> WHO ARE THE CAPTAINS?
WHO MAKES THE COIN TOSS CALL?
YEAH, THEY ARE ON THE ROAD, SO
IT WOULD BE COWBOYS WHO MAKE
THE CALL.
>> I THINK IT IS MICHAEL
PARSONS.
I THINK IT IS PARSONS, DAK, NO,
DeMARCUS LAWRENCE AND DAK.
I BELIEVE THAT'S IT.
I WILL TRUST THEM.
THEY'VE WON 11 TIMES THIS YEAR.
THAT IS TIED FOR THIRD.
I'M GOING TO SAY YES  BASED ON
THE COIN TOSS.
>> I LIKE IT.
I LIKE IT.
>> RYAN IS ROCKING WITH A
GUESS.
SAM IS ROCKING WITH A YES.
NO, WAIT, SAM, WHO WAS YOUR
VERDICT?
>> I'M TAKING THE NO.
>> SAM IS WORKING WITH THE
KNOW.
WHATEVER SIDE YOU ARE ON, GET
ON DRAFTKINGS AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT PROFIT BOOST,
BUT RIGHT NOW, RIGHT NOW, WE
ARE SAVING THE BEST FOR LAST.
I PURPOSELY WENT OUT OF ORDER
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO SAVE THE
BEST FOR LAST.
RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME FOR OUR
BEST BETS, AND HERE IS THE DEAL
THIS WEEK.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
SAM AND I, WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING WE LOVE, SO WE ARE
LETTING RYAN, RYAN, TONIGHT,
IT'S YOUR NIGHT.
IT IS YOUR NIGHT.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT
TONIGHT?
>> THIS IS THE RYAN SHOW.
IT'S ALL ABOUT RYAN.
>> PUT THE CHEFS HAT ON ME.
I LOVE TO COOK.
I LOVE, LOVE, LOVE, LET ME SEE
IF I GO JUST SHOW IT, AND I
WILL DISPLAY IT AT THE SAME
TIME AS I SAY IT.
COWBOYS TEAM TOTAL POINTS
TONIGHT IS THAT 26.5.
THE COWBOYS, THIS IS NO
HYPERBOLE, ARE GOING TO SCORE A
GOOD JILLIAN POINTS TONIGHT ON
THE TENNESSEE TITANS.
THIS IS A PRESEASON GAME FOR
THE TITANS.
THEY ARE STARTING THEIR
PRACTICE SQUAD.
THE COWBOY SAYS DAK HAS
RETURNED FROM INJURY HAVE
SCORED NO LESS THAN 24 POINTS
IN EVERY GAME THAT HE HAS
PLAYED . THIS IS, I AM THE MAN
OF THE PEOPLE, BUT I AM ALSO
MR. FIVE-TO ON HIS BEST BETS ON
THE SHOW, AND AFTER TODAY,
AFTER TONIGHT, WE WILL BE 6-2.
THIS IS GOING TO SMACK.
THIS IS ONE OF THE EASIER, I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GUYS LOOKED
AT THIS GAME AND SAID YOU
DIDN'T LOVE SOMETHING, BECAUSE
I LOOKED AT THIS AND I FELL IN
LOVE.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME I EVER
SAID, WOW, I THINK I'M IN LOVE.
WHEN I SAW THIS TEAM TOTAL
OVER.
THIS IS BEAUTIFUL.
>> WORRY ABOUT YOUR PERSONAL
LIFE IN THAT CASE.
>> I WILL OFF-LINE.
HOW ABOUT THE COWBOYS ARE NOT
GOING TO SCORED 27 POINTS?
HOW?
HOW IS THAT GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
THE ONLY CHANCE IS IF THEY COUGH
--
>> OR IF A METEOR HITS THE
EARTH.
PROBABLY THE LATTER IS THE ONLY
THING THAT CAN STOP THEM.
LIKE, I JUST CAN'T SEE THEM,
AND ONE WORLD ARE THEY CALLING
THE DOGS OFF EARLY BEFORE THEY
GET TO 27 POINTS?
>> IF THEY ARE OPEN 21-3 IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER AGAINST JOSH
DOBBS --
>> I JUST CAN'T SEE THEM ONLY
SCORING 21 POINTS.
BY THE TIME THEY GET TO THE
FOURTH QUARTER, I AM ASSUMING
65 TO 75 POINTS WILL ALREADY BE
SCORED BY THE COWBOYS BY THE
TIME THEY GET TO THE FOURTH
QUARTER.
>> I HOPE YOU ARE CLIPPING THIS
OUT AFTER THE SHOW IN
CELEBRATION.
>> I WILL.
>> WE ARE GOING TO SEE.
RYAN , WE ARE GOING TO SEE.
>> BUT THAT'S IT.
THAT'S IT.
I'M READY TO GO WIN SOME BETS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU GUYS.
HOPEFULLY YOU GUYS AND THAT
CHAT ARE READY TO GO WIN.
YOU WANT TO GIVE THEM A RECAP
BEFORE WE GET UP OUT OF HERE?
>> YES.
OUR FIVE LEG SAME GAME PARLAY IS
UNDER 17.5 TEAM PUT TOTAL
POINTS FOR THE TENNESSEE
TITANS, OVER 54.5 RECEIVING
YARDS FOR CEEDEE THEM, OVER 2.5
TOTAL TOUCHDOWNS FOR THE DALLAS
COWBOYS, 195+ PASSING YARDS FOR
DAK PRESCOTT , AND THEN, AN
ANYTIME FIRST HALF TOUCHDOWN
FOR ZEKE.
FIVE LEG AT  +575.
IT'S A LOT.
>> THERE IT IS.
RYAN CALLED IT A LOCK.
THERE IT IS.
>> THE TEAM TOTAL OVER IS MORE
OF A LOCK, BUT THIS WILL ALSO
HIT.
>> RYAN CALLED IT A LOCK.
HE LIKES HIS TEAM TOTAL OVER.
MAKE SURE YOU TELL US ON
DRAFTKINGS.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY.
NEXT TO ME IS SAM, THE MAN THE
MYTH THE LEGEND RICHMOND, NEXT
TO HIM IS A GUY WE LIKE TO CALL
PRODUCER RYAN AROUND THESE
PARTS.
WE ARE ABOUT TO GO WIN SOME
MONEY, SO WE ARE UP OUT OF
HERE.
HE'S.